[Music]  congratulations are in order for George  and Amal the talk has confirmed that the  55 year old superstar and his highly  accomplished 39 year old attorney Weiss  are expecting twins the twins are due  this June it's official  George and Amal Clooney are expecting  we've been fascinated with this pair  ever since they tie the knot in  September 2014  since then the burning question has been  one of the babies coming aren't you nice  you know been my mother George and Amal  first expanded their family with this  precious pooch the Clooney's adopted  Milly a four year old basset hound  George is set to make one great family  man just listen to the proud husband  gush about his wife she's amazing human  being and she's caring and she also  happens to be one of the smartest people  I've ever met Congrats to the Clooney